one of Westar Ford's largest border
towns mestere is burning
as the chadian military approach
they can do nothing
as we were approaching it looked like
Mist over the valley but as we got
closer you can see that as plumes of
smoke Rising above Villages that have
been scorched by ethnic conflict
we drive further east and find its
latest victims
seeking shelter under every other tree
still in a State of Shock
people are dying and shama says the war
is still raging
I ask her if they'll come seeking
treatment but she says they're still
trapped inside
and the horror stories are all around us
Miriam says her 11 year old nephew was
killed by the fighting she fled with the
other children and her pregnant daughter
where is his mother I ask she says she's
still missing
this is the crossing point a dried
riverbed they're safe in Chad now but
can still see and hear the signs of
wreckage
this Valley is officially that foreign
just across the way you can hear
gunfires still ringing out of the
villages where fighting continues and
all of these people here have come
across to look for safety from what they
see is a continued targeted assault
you can hear it now
she says that's the sound of rifles the
very rifles that they fled to come here
foreign is your family there I ask the
chorus replies yes they're in there
being killed
Chad's border with Sudan has technically
been closed since the early days of the
war but violence in Darfur has meant
civilians are permitted to cross this
border must be very difficult to police
no
oh come on
[Music]
some stay on the border to Bear Witness
while in adre the wounded start coming
in
she looks so young these casualties are
pouring in from the village that we saw
burning and all of them seemed to be hit
by gunshots
[Music]
just three years old even Bilal wasn't
spared from the bullets
[Music]
and his older sister is forced to watch
their mother is still trapped but many
are making their way out
[Music]
this man and his son have escaped the
regional capital of elginena where a
massacre has been reported
I asked him to tell me what's happening
there he says death daily death
the survivors keep streaming in
pained by bullet wounds and a familiar
Grim reality
Sky News Eastern chant